this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up guys michael here now before
we get into it i want you to stick
around till the end of the video because
we have some news about our patreon page
and i am excited to share it with you
today i want to tell you about an
exciting new product sart shades the
only glasses designed to help you watch
youtube videos while filtering out all
gestures of bad faith and denials of
your brutal existential freedom
not just kidding but i do want to talk
about celebrity endorsements they're
nothing new early star fatty arbuckle
was talking murad brand cigarettes back
in 1905 after all but we're totally
fascinated by a new trend that's taking
the celebrity world by storm endorsing
cryptocurrency and nfts nfts or
non-fungible tokens are digital deeds to
digital assets think of it as the deed
to a house but that deed is made of
computer code and instead of a house you
can live in you're now the proud owner
of a jpeg nfts are purchased almost
exclusively with you guessed it crypto
and because the crypto market is so new
and mostly unregulated nfts are ripe for
hype speculation and fortunes to be
gained or as many experts warn lost side
note if you want to learn more about the
nft market check out our video on it and
if you can't even carry on a
conversation about crypto we've got a
video for you too um but you know please
finish this one first please lately it
seems like celebrities are actually
making fetch happen with nfts stop
trying to make fetch happen it's not
going to happen paris hilton for
instance has appeared on jimmy fallon
multiple times to talk about them
initially to school him on the topic
then to compare her bored ape yacht club
nft artwork with his we're part of the
same people partisan community we're
both apes i love it uh here's my this is
my
and eventually to surprise the audience
with nft art of their very own which she
designed herself paris we have no notes
if you love it so much i actually want
to give you the first one
i would
i would be honored and i want to give
one to everyone in the audience
all of this is treated as if it were
normal as if she were promoting say her
new book album or line of designer
youtube sunglasses
a fortune has even gone so far as to
name hilton one of the 50 most
influential people in nfts and it's not
just paris and jimmy john stamos bought
an nft profile pic reese witherspoon
just optioned ip made from an nft for a
film and matt damon used his 35 year old
career to promote crypto at the super
bowl fortune favors the brave
and of course there's larry david who's
spending his golden years doing this
yeah i don't think so
and i'm never wrong about this stuff
never
so what's the deal why are celebrities
gaga for nfts and crypto in general and
what does it say about our fame hungry
society let's find out in this wisecrack
edition celebrities and nfts a match
made in hell
but before we dive in i want to talk
about this week's sponsor surfsharkvpn
surfsharkvpn's uncrackable encryption
and secure protocols help keep your data
secure as you click around the internet
there are so many upsides to using a
secure vpn like surfshark among them
there's the knowledge that i'm getting
the best prices available when i'm
shopping online how because if a website
doesn't know where in the world i am
they can't inflate their prices based on
what country i'm in and this can result
in huge savings especially when shopping
for things like airplane tickets and
don't forget the secure file sharing
that comes with surfsharkvpn by
encrypting all of your internet traffic
it makes downloads safe and secure which
means nobody at wisecrack will ever know
that i've been saving copies of all the
close-up footage ever taken in my face
all while still on the clock please do
not tell anyone with just one
subscription all of your favorite
devices are covered we're talking about
your laptop android playstation and xbox
amazon fire stick and beyond and you'll
find options for your favorite apps too
like firefox and chrome so get started
today by clicking the link in the
description and using the promo code
wisecrack when you do you can get surf
shark vpn for 83 off plus three extra
months for free go to surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today and now back
to the show
celebrity is as old as nfts are new some
consider alexander the great the first
celebrity ever thanks to his power
riches and face pretty enough to slap on
a coin but celebrity culture as we know
it today as scholar thomas mole argues
really got going in the romantic era
when certain authors started cultivating
public personality something we might
now call personal brands like lord byron
who became famous not just for his dank
poems but also for the way he dressed
and the way he behaved including being a
bit of a dirt bag with the ladies the
19th century brought the emergence of
photography which changed everything
indeed abraham lincoln personally
credited a photographer of a widely
circulated image of him as a chief
reason he was elected president while
painted portraiture had long been a
thing for the rich and famous
photography newly allowed for the mass
dissemination of images often images of
humans especially famous humans with
each subsequent technology that followed
images and then moving images of
celebrity became more and more
accessible until we wind up with
cristiano ronaldo setting the record for
the most instagram followers ever and
the more images of celebrities
circulated the bigger and broader
celebrity became
and this makes sense after all celebrity
is all about being visible being seen in
this sense celebrities can cynically be
considered commodities that are consumed
i.e looked at by the masses and as
scholar primodner points out in his book
seeing stars there's not really a
meaningful difference between say a
promotional campaign for diet coke and a
promotional campaign for a living
breathing celebrity after all
celebrities he says are materials to be
branded and sold fame is a manufactured
product manufactured in and by the mass
media for public consumption a tabloid
magazine for instance may be its own
standalone commodity but it's predicated
on even more commodities the celebrities
being reported on because celebrities
are essentially commodities themselves
perhaps it's no surprise that they've
long been seen as essential to creating
and sustaining the demand necessary for
the consumer economy as scholar p david
marshall puts it celebrity taught
generations how to engage and use
consumer culture to make oneself i.e
celebrity and consumerism were a match
made in capitalist heaven which is also
known as regular hell this was happening
back in those romantic years when people
bought roughly shirts to make themselves
look a touch more like lord byron for
instance but that was nothing compared
to how the inextricable relationship
between celebrity and consumer culture
has grown in the years that followed
magazines from the 1940s reported
breathlessly on how stars spend their
fortune showcasing their glamorous homes
and enviable spending habits first lady
jackie kennedy's fondness for chanel
suits among other sleek designs
practically defined 60s fashion mtv crib
showed us that the ultimate ideal of a
dope-ass house might have its own
dedicated lingerie closet or 35
bathrooms basically it's a version of
monkey c monkey really wants to do but
instead of foraging for bananas we're
reaching for new markers of class and
taste i saw katie herron wearing army
pants and flip-flops so i bought army
pants and flip-flops and nowhere is the
relationship between consumer culture
and celebrity more obvious than with
celebrity endorsements so why do
celebrity endorsement sell everything
from cars to coors light so well
neher argues that it's because of the
phenomenon of transferred celebrity i.e
the product becomes associated with the
qualities of the human celebrity so
let's say it's 2004 you love britney
spears and you want everyone to know it
and to also associate you with how cool
she is by buying a pair of the skechers
she recently endorsed in the pages of
teen people you're trying to imbue
yourself with as much of britney's
bubblegum charm as you can
even if you don't explicitly realize
that's what you're doing now britney is
a celebrity in her own right because
she's a hard-working triple threat but
if she's out here selling skechers she's
imbuing it with clout and those sweet
sweet kicks are reinforcing that clout
right back at her to paraphrase scholar
richard dyer celebrities are both labor
i.e varying combinations of talent
hotness work ethic and luck and the
thing that labor produces i.e fame and
fortune so it follows that when people
with major fan bases endorse a product
not only does the celebrity get more
attention in the public eye but the
product itself will see a boost in
profits and prestige what babe ruth did
for cola or oprah did for weight
watchers or michael jordan did for nike
is something the makers of nfts are
ready to harness for a new century now
you've seen justin bieber somehow make
crocs seem cool and a water bottle
became spiritually rejuvenating because
of jennifer aniston but something
different happens with crypto and nfts
which after all don't tangibly exist in
the real world because they're so
intangible these non-fungible tokens are
ironically
very fungible in terms of what they can
potentially signify when paris endorses
them they're glamorous when spike lee
endorses crypto it's righteous and bold
when gwyneth paltrow does it you're
living that crunchy yet chic holistic
lifestyle crypto and by extension nfts
are the perfect empty vessel upon which
to project a celebrity's entire affect
and nowadays there's an nft happy
celebrity for seemingly every
demographic even eric andre's into it
who would have thought absurdist
comedians even knew about nfts but when
you're buying an nft to emulate your
favorite celebrity it's like an even
bigger dopamine hit than buying those
adorable spears skechers you feel closer
to them and more importantly more
similar to them than ever before before
you only had the pleasure of consuming
like a celebrity now you have the
pleasure of investing like a celebrity
what here high-end vip exclusive that's
liable to make you feel richer and more
glamorous than say
drinking a pepsi at a protest
after all as nair says celebrities
embody an abstract desire to achieve to
be recognized to be wealthy
poverty-stricken celebrities would be
hard to find celebrities represent what
people aspire to feed or to possess and
in a world where financial security is
anything but easy to come by emulating
the investment choices of an already
wealthy celebrity might not seem like
the worst option
now we're not grumps if you want to
smell like mariah carey or buy car
insurance like shaq have a ball but
there are issues of accountability at
stake when celebrities use their power
to change our consumption habits what
was supposed to be a historically
significant tiffany and co campaign
starring beyonce and jay-z
got a bit thorny when the 128-carat
yellow diamond beyonce war turned out to
be for all intents and purposes a 30
million dollar vintage blood diamond fyi
bay and j released a statement
denouncing the jewelry or consider this
adorable retro ad of lucille ball
shilling chesterfields so cute and so
cigarettes
and we'll keep our adjectives to
ourselves about the results of diet
pills and flat tummy tees and maybe
that's why the celeb sensation
surrounding nfts feels so uncomfortable
diet pills might give you the runs but
nfts are a different beast altogether at
best they're too new to fully judge as a
major investment and at worst by many
accounts
they're a pyramid scheme it's worth
noting that celebrity ben mckenzie aka
ryan from the oc is getting attention
lately for actually dunking on nfts
welcome to the off chain [ __ ]
but think about it when you buy one of
paris hilton's bedazzled boss babe
hoodies you have like 100 bucks at stake
which isn't nothing but it probably
isn't all of your rent money but when
she essentially recruits you by way of a
talk show to buy an nft she's doing
something else entirely see nft owners
have essentially banked on a speculative
asset if paris wants to see the value of
that asset grow she needs the general
public to flood the nft market with
capital essentially to bolster her major
investment and that's where things get
tricky the allure of feeling like your
lifestyle is closer to hers or to any
rich and famous persons has the capacity
to wreck your finances and that's what
we're seeing unfold with kim
kardashian's endorsement of ethereum max
it's a developing story at the time of
this video but the tl dr is this kim
uploaded a sponsored instagram story
promoting ethereum max right after the
company had burned half of their
available bitcoin that means they put
them in an essentially locked crypto
wallet where they can't be distributed
that created market scarcity which drove
up the price for people who were eager
to buy ethereum max after being
influenced by kim's story she and other
famous influencers are currently being
sued because ethereum max's prices shot
up thirteen hundred percent before
totally crashing a month later the
lawsuit alleges that it was a pump and
dump scheme as far as we can tell the
people who bought high watched their big
investments basically light on fire in
front of their eyes but in addition to
being morally dubious this whole
situation is also just really really
surreal think about who paris hilde and
kim kardashian are
famous people who literally invented
their celebrity out of nothing or that
is became famous purely by being seen
and here they are endorsing a product
that by many estimations is essentially
also
made up is this the most meta thing ever
maybe and we think that's best
understood through a concept from
classical political economy
use value
see use value as the name suggests is a
measurement of how an object derives
value from its usefulness this pair of
galoshes great for keeping my feet dry
in the rain this spoon excellent for
shoveling cheese whiz into my mouth yeah
i eat cheese with a spoon not a
barbarian i don't put elf cans in my
mouth everything that humans consider
valuable has a use value going all the
way up to actual people the use value of
zendaya for breaking your heart on
screen the use value of doji cat for
writing total bangers and the use value
of serena williams for changing the game
of tennis when these celebrities endorse
things there are two use values at play
that of the celebrity i.e their fame and
respective talents and that of the
product say the beautifying effects of
mascara or the refreshment of some frost
arctic blitz but for celebs like paris
and kim their fame is a purely ephemeral
commodity with no obvious use value
their celebrity isn't linked to tangible
talents beyond you know sharing really
innovative thoughts on work ethic get
your ass up and work and this is where
things get even more meta marxist
economics talks about what happens when
a commodity's value becomes detached
from the actual thing that can be bought
sold or traded like when a pair of nikes
becomes less about helping you avoid
ankle sprains and more about what it
represents the fearlessness of serena
williams in this way the commodity
essentially becomes a theological entity
something that transcends use value it's
now a spiritual thing with what one
german economist called metaphysical
subtleties and theological niceties so
we have two things one celebrities
without use value or celebrities that
have been constructed out of thin air
using their clout to push two nfts which
have a use value that's arguably also
constructed out of thin air the whole
thing starts to feel like a digital
house of cards if celebrities who have
value simply for having value are now
pushing digital commodities that also
have value simply for having value
it seems like maybe we're all just
emperors without any clothes but what do
you guys think if it brings someone
actual joy to feel like they are a
player in the marketplace on par with
paltrow or eric andre
is there really any harm in it should we
just let people enjoy things and say a
little prayer that doesn't lead to their
financial ruin and if it does should
celebrities feel bad about that or even
be held accountable let us know in the
comments okay i said at the top i wanted
to tell you about our new patreon page
and now i'm gonna do that um we've
recently updated our patreon we added
new levels new perks and new exclusive
content i think that you will all like
it a lot um so let's say you want to
know more about how we make our videos
what goes into the research and the
writing we got you we're starting a new
uh series on the patreon page where
we're gonna interview writers and
editors and researchers who all make
these videos and get a more in-depth
picture of what goes into them on their
research the idea is what gets left on
the cutting room floor all that stuff
now if you ever watch the videos and
want more in-depth discussion of some of
the philosophy we talk about i got you
there i'm going to start doing a regular
series
of sort of philosophy office hours where
i'm going to dig deeper into a lot of
the stuff we talk about on the channel
and a lot of the philosophy and concepts
that go into the videos i'll get into
that i'm also going to create space for
question and answer stuff so you can
just ask me stuff and i could try to
answer it all without having to take on
any more student loan debt so yay
but that's all on our patreon page now
please check it out and if you're
already one of our patrons first thank
you second check it out as well there
might be some new stuff that you don't
know about that you'll be excited to see
as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you